somos un país diverso pero somos un país
rico y variado somos un país que se
enorgullece de eso por lo menos es la
afirmación oficial en los distintos
espacios públicos incluyendo los medios
de comunicación pero qué es lo que pasa
en realidad sería mucho más específica
que lo que pasa cuando inicia diversidad
te encuentras en el grupo minoritario
- en número pero menos
también en valía por lo menos esa es la
afirmación que nos hacen de manera
reiterada en esta sociedad pero además
debemos aceptar todo esto con sonrisas
con carcajadas con humor negro y mucha
mucha complacencia y mucho mucho
agradecimiento
somos un país de más de 30 millones de
habitantes según el censo del 2017 de
los cuales el 25% se autoidentifica
indígena andino el 1% son indígenas
amazónicos y el 4% somos
afro peruanas y afro peruanos somos un
país diverso cultural y étnicamente y
racialmente y voy a hablar de raza
porque sigue siendo una categoría de
análisis que nos permite reconocer que
las personas y los grupos pueden tener
oportunidades o barreras para su
desarrollo a partir de su color de piel
de su etnia y de su fenotipo y esto no
lo estoy diciendo yo hay evidencia al
respecto cuáles decirles por ejemplo que
el 16 por ciento de personas que se
autoidentifican blancas y mestizas se
encuentran en una situación de
crecimiento a diferencia de un 33 por
ciento de personas que se
autoidentifican afrodescendientes un 28
por ciento de personas indígenas andinas
se encuentran también en situación de
pobreza y un 46 por ciento de indígenas
amazónicos también es decir la pobreza
tiene color e incluso debemos decir
tiene genio
ahora a mí se me hace un poco difícil
hablar en primera persona sobre todo
cuando tenemos que referirnos a temas
que sin duda me impactan directamente
como son el racismo el sexismo el
machismo pero hoy toca hacerlo y toca
hacerlo porque en mi historia mi
experiencia no es un hecho aislado es la
historia y es la experiencia de muchas
mujeres afrodescendientes no solamente
del perú sino de distintas partes del
mundo e incluso de mujeres de otras
etnias mujeres y personas racial izadas
de distintas partes del mundo
vamos a entender que esta situación que
me afecta que nos afecta tiene un
sustento en el racismo estructural que
atraviesa nuestras sociedades y se
manifiesta de distintas formas y de
distintas maneras en el perú le dicen
sutil al racismo personalmente yo no le
veo nada de sutil es dolorosamente
visible y representan los sí y los no
que hemos tenido y tenemos en nuestras
vidas y que determinan nuestro
desarrollo pleno
hoy me gustaría también
a partir de esta reflexión que ustedes
intenten imaginarse siendo
afrodescendientes en el perú o personas
negras si es que prefieren utilizar ese
término particularmente yo me auto
identifico como afro peruana porque
cuestionó el término negro término
colonizador que precisamente se colocó a
los africanos y afrodescendientes para
decirles que no eran nada que no tenían
alma simplemente no existía luego les
cuento desde cuando nos decimos y nos
auto identificamos de manera oficial
como afrodescendientes
pero bueno
entonces retomamos y ya ustedes están
imaginando siendo afrodescendientes
obviamente yo no me lo tengo que
imaginar yo soy yo van a sofía carrillo
segarra soy una mujer afro peruana afro
feminista periodista hija de dos
chinchanos felipe carrillo rivas y sofía
se agarra de la cruz 95% chinchana 5%
limeña diría mi madre entonces yo no me
lo imagino ustedes si se lo imaginan
ahora que ya son personas
afrodescendientes empiecen a ver el
escenario y vamos a los medios de
comunicación recuerden el programa que
vieron el fin de semana recuerden el
programa que vieron en la niñez y del
cual se rieron tanto o disfrutaron donde
estaban los afrodescendientes
estaba primero primera pregunta si
estaban segunda qué rol ocupaban por
ejemplo en los programas de ficción
los roles ustedes lo saben al igual que
yo eran el chofer la empleada del hogar
también la bailarina la trabajadora
sexual entonces
salimos de la ficción y nos vamos a la
realidad
ustedes afrodescendientes van a la
escuela van al trabajo y nuevamente
miren a su alrededor
cuántos afrodescendientes trabajan con
ustedes y en qué cargos
recuerdan al niño a la niña
afrodescendiente del colegio que le
decían no ponían la música afroperuana y
le decían baila baila baila tú debes
bailar bonito te des mover bien y no
para apreciar su talento sino para que
sea tu divertimento
distinto si eres tú el afrodescendiente
si eres tu la afrodescendiente es cierto
yo reitero no me lo tengo que imaginar y
el tema aquí no es que los
afrodescendientes o los afro peruanos no
seamos empleadas del hogar choferes
cocineros bailarines estamos orgullosos
y orgullosas de serlo el tema es que no
es lo único que hacemos y el problema
con los estereotipos está en eso en que
toma una
un solo aspecto de la realidad para
colocarla como única y esto representa
también barrera para que nosotras
realmente podamos desarrollarnos en
otros espacios en la ciencia en la
política en los medios de comunicación
espacios que también deberían ser
nuestros
por lo tanto colocándose unos instantes
en esos escenarios como
afrodescendientes
ustedes han observado a su alrededor y
sientan por un momento y sé
sentimiento y esa frustración que puede
producir te el no verte el no reconocer
t el que no haya más gente como tú y no
porque no tengan capacidades o porque no
quieran hacerlo simplemente porque las
puertas se cierran y se cierran de
manera reiterada
todo esto se constituyen violencias que
hemos asumido y que nosotras y nosotros
seguimos cuestionando y estamos luchando
para que terminen pero también quiero
decir que muchas afrodescendientes y
muchos afrodescendientes hemos entendido
y hemos asumido todas estas violencias
como la motivación para decir que
tenemos la posibilidad de cambiar la
realidad que vamos a ir contra la
corriente que queremos que no hayan más
niñas niños adolescentes y mujeres
hipersexualizadas discriminadas
racializada y animalistas
pero esa esperanza de la cual
estoy hablando va a tener sentido si
cada uno de nosotras de nosotros y de
ustedes asumen una posición
necesitas ser afrodescendiente para
sumarte a la lucha
ya no necesita ser afrodescendiente lo
que necesitas y es reconocer los
derechos de los afrodescendientes y
reconocer tus privilegios si eres una
persona no racializada
no necesitas imaginarte ser
afrodescendiente simplemente actúa y no
seas indiferente ante el racismo ante
las manifestaciones del mismo de
distintas maneras
y les dije hace unos minutos que cada
uno de nosotros debe asumir un papel y
también les dije que yo me auto
identifico como afrodescendiente desde
hace muchísimo tiempo y esto también
tiene una base no histórica una base de
lucha en el 2001
se reunieron en durban casi todos los
estados del mundo en sudáfrica
y señalaron que cada uno de los países
tenía que reparar a las víctimas de la
esclavización es decir a los africanos y
afrodescendientes entonces nosotros
decimos que a durban en tramos negros y
salimos afrodescendientes nos conectamos
con nuestra madre áfrica y nos
reconocemos como hermanos y hermanas
como hijas e hijos de la diáspora
africana
este cambio personal e individual del
cual hemos hablado tiene que estar
acompañado también de cambios políticos
de un estado que garantice la
participación activa de los
afrodescendientes en los distintos
espacios pero ojo con esto no solamente
estamos planteando nuestra presencia
como figuras decorativas estamos
planteando la necesidad de reconocernos
como sujetas y sujetos de derechos que
cuando hablemos de educación de calidad
coloquemos explícitamente educación anti
racista que permita que ninguna mujer u
hombre afrodescendiente vuelva por
ejemplo a ser impedido a ingresar a un
espacio público por su color de piel
como le pasó a mi madre como le pasó a
mis abuelos que ninguna
tenga ganas de desaparecer en su salón
de clase cuando hablan de esclavitud
porque es el único momento en el cual se
refieren a los afrodescendientes y la
miran no y la colocan como una sujeta
pasiva complaciente
pese al abuso y a la explotación
eso es lo que nosotras y nosotros
tenemos que cambiar y eso es lo que el
estado también debe cambiar nosotros
exigimos al estado por ejemplo que
cuando se hable de paridad se entienda a
las mujeres en su diversidad que no
estamos hablando de una categoría única
que las mujeres afrodescendientes
también tenemos esos espacios que las
mujeres indígenas andinas y amazónicas
también requieren y tienen derecho a
esos espacios
y decirles también que cuando ustedes se
asumieron como afrodescendientes
seguramente no esperaban lástima o pena
como tampoco la espero yo en estos
momentos seguro que no porque lo que
estamos diciendo y lo que planteamos es
que ante las acusaciones reiteradas de
victimización que nos hacen a los
afrodescendientes y a quienes
denunciamos el racismo y las diversas
formas de discriminación
puedan realmente reconocernos en nuestro
derecho reitero a vivir una vida libre
de discriminación porque vivimos
sonrientes vivimos también felices con
la fuerza que nos dan nuestros ancestros
que nos dan nuestras ancestras si ellas
pudieron si ellos pudieron porque
nosotros y nosotras no vamos a poder
ya no te imagines siendo
afrodescendiente tampoco digas que te
hubiera encantado tener nuestro cabello
o nuestro color de piel
simplemente respetamos simplemente actúa
no seas indiferente todas todos y todos
merecemos ser parte de este mundo en
igualdad de oportunidades en igualdad de
condiciones las mujeres diversas estamos
en este país y estamos en el mundo las
mujeres afrodescendientes en el perú
existimos y este mundo este país también
es de nosotras de nosotros y de nosotros
ah